das ist meine wohnung in köln 60
sie renovieren und das alles hier auf
eingerichtet geht das nicht gut was mir
quadratmeter 2000 euro beim all in und
handel dieser völlig krank und ich kann
mich wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat
lassen er gerne in leichter vergessen
am besten gefällt ist dass es nicht so
da ich sie mir mit einem mitbewohner
irgendwie verstehen für den teil seines
nicht den kanal zu abonnieren damit die
komplett neubau ist sondern das ist so
teile 500 euro pro person aber wie sieht
grenzer videos verpasst wenn ich das
lebens mal in new york gelebt haben ist
eingangsbereich steht also stühlen oder
ist wie man sich so eine new yorker
es eigentlich in anderen städten ländern
ganze in anderen städten noch mache wir
schon sehr nice und ich bin nicht der
platz also ich hatte vorher gedacht das
das kommen wir ins kurze eck und spart
wohnung herstellt
einzige der so denkt leute von überall
oder kontinenten aus nachdem ich bereits
sehen uns in ein paar tagen schon wieder
aus der welt wollen hinziehen was
vielen dank das gut
geschaut habe wie weit man mit 100 oder
wär vielleicht so klein dass man nicht
natürlich dazu beiträgt dass die preise
gehen wir mal schätzungsweise einfach
nicht so
sogar tausend euro new york city als
vernünftig im spektrum an umgehen kann
so steigt bereits solche mieten und
von 50 quadratmetern dann würden sie für
und so aber es ist ja schon richtig
toni kommt will ich heute herausfinden
preise darf aber in kauf zu nehmen wäre
ordentlich platz der mann hat mehr platz
eine 50 quadratmeter wohnung mit zwei
wie leute in new york city wirklich
ich nicht um ein bisschen besser
verstehen zu können warum es aber doch
als man dachte dass ich find's cool und
leben und was es für besonderheiten gut
zimmern zu dritt 2400 euro bezahlen das
so viele leute tun habe ich meinen
einfach kann man nicht viel falsch
viel spaß mit so liebmann für 2400
kollegen angerufen der nach new york
die war ein gericht komplett dass er
machen
sind 48 dollar pro quadratmeter 44 euro
gezogen ist der erste befund ist schon
dollar in new york city von meiner und
seit drei monate hier komplett also rein
mal das halt auch in jobs hier zu zeigen
dass ich in einem anderen video getestet
pro quadratmeter und damit mehr als
werden aus ihren stehen und liegen
dass man in der küche schon
habe musste ich tatsächlich nur 15
doppelt so teuer als die teuerste stadt
dazu setzt also kehrt ihr saft sonst als
minuten zu fuß gehen bzw 5 minuten
in deutschland in münchen ist okay jetzt
kommentiert mein ansatz ist immer
amerikanischen kühlschrank kühlschrank
radfahren um bei der wohnung anzukommen
könnte man sich aber fragen die wohnung
ähnlich gross hat auch hier sind ein
weil die in einer seitenstraße vom times
ohne eis hatte gehofft in amerika nur
ich gehe dieses gerät auf die alter
scheint ja ziemlich günstig zu sein 2400
können das bedeutet gleichzeitig dass
soja schränke mit so heiß wird's wieder
generell viel höher ist als deutschland
paar stand ist ich bin zurück und
die wohnung ziemlich lahm central park
dollar bei einem durchschnittspreis der
das leben kostet er fiel aber die kannst
ist was ziemlich nass ist damit man in
unterbot mit
eingepackt zu finden
eigentlich bereits 2900 dollar liegt
typisch new yorker feuer treffen
so einer großen stadt irgendwie mal ins
wieso ist das so die preise in new york
du auch sehr kreativ was glaubst du was
grüne kommt und bevor wir uns jetzt die
sagst du so im monat auf essen
wohnung anschauen habe ich mich erst mal
für wohnungen schwanken enorm gerade
informiert wie es mit den mieten gerade
während krone in der zeit wo ich auch
verpflegung
aktuell im juli auch so aussieht und es
ja hier ist unser essen bereich
dieses video vor gedreht hat konnte man
nicht quatsch kraft vertreten
da gehst du denn rauchen echt also
ist komplett
beobachten dass die preise unglaublich
also da ist einem monat auch was seine
brauchen wir echt geil draußen also drei
kaske drop sind und wohnungen super
mit gegessen
günstig angeboten wurden mittlerweile
deine 150 dollar ein so viel kath.net
sind sie wieder hoch sogar auf eine
zimmer wie viel quadratmeter oder 22
das kann's gar keine zeit die noch
molkerei also die bieten waren noch nie
dagegen als einer woche essen um die 30
seit jahren steigen die mieten so sehr
teurer in new york zu dem zeitpunkt
zimmer küche bad diesmal aber es sind 35
ausklappen zu einem bett haben wir uns
konnte man aber tatsächlich ziemlich
dass kein witz jeden tag in den news
dollar
günstig wohnen kommt und die leute die
auch schon zweiter mann kompetent feiern
180 dollar senats ist auch schon 15 und
darüber berichtet wird alle diese
zu der zeit eine günstige wohnung
berichte die ihr gerade seht sind von
wo sind wir hier in hell's kitchen das
angemietet haben werden jetzt zum großen
was du aber wissen wieder hinziehen
hier ist unser ziel dass wir großes bett
einem tag und es gibt noch viel mehr new
teilen von dem glenn close aus der
diese frage habe ich die beste
ist so sechs sieben minuten von vom
wohnung raus geschmissen weil sie die
york ist auf platz drei der teuersten
trägt bei der straße relativ laut aber
mich wieder anziehen wollen also es geht
mit städte weltweit mit durchschnittlich
lebensqualität geben hat jemals mein
times square im zentrum
alles ganz ganz billig aber ist genug
wirklich hoch und runter und hoch und
2900 dollar für eine zweizimmerwohnung
eigentlich war die geilste lage so wenn
runter aber momentan all time high
vater und ich dachte die erlebst sind
die um die 50 quadratmetern und dabei
man nur drei monate hier ist klar ein
wahrscheinlich sind die wohnung momentan
unbezahlbar obwohl ich das richtig ist
durchschnittlich sogar deutlich teurer
bisschen lauter so aber dafür mittendrin
macht es natürlich einen unterschied wo
besser denn das land will ich machen
als 2900 euro im
man ist aber es ist und bleibt teuer
über die bars restaurants kneipen das
wenn ich allerdings haben wirklich auf
selbst 30 minuten in jede richtung quasi
und weil dieses video zu einer reihe
ist halt besser zu machen kannst um wie
die auch die jobs werden linden simon
aus new york raus oder aus manhattan
gehört die ich in zukunft in anderen
viel zahlt hier pro monat zur alt drei
raus ist und bleibt ist teuer später im
ländern städten beziehungsweise
kontinenten drehen will wird es jetzt
leuten
und anton haben sich genau das gedacht
video habe ich auch noch mit einer
person gesprochen die in new york lebt
2450 und ok also 800 euro pro
sind auf deutschland nach new york
ein ranking einen quadratmeterpreis
und die hat mir gesagt dass man sich
gezogen und deren wohnung schauen wir
ranking es gibt bis dato nur eine
schon sehr glücklich schätzen kann wenn
uns jetzt an
man wirklich eine zweizimmerwohnung für
wohnung die wir uns angeschaut haben
ich glaube irgendwo in einem dieser
2900 dollar finden sollte und um das zu
aber auf platz eins der teuersten
wohnung ist diese wohnung mit 44 euro
häuser müsste sein 40 74 05 er ist ein
verdeutlichen hier kurz einen
verantworten aus einer straßenumfrage in
pro quadratmeter vielleicht fragt sich
der new yorker gefragt wurden was sie
der eine oder andere jetzt auch wie zur
für ihre wohnung bezahlen steht dies im
hölle komme ich darauf so ein video zu
machen eben verschiedenen ländern
verschiedene wohnungen anzuschauen
tatsächlich interessiert es mich einfach
nicht interessiert ist nicht nur in
anderen ländern und anderen kulturen und
anderen städten und kontinenten sondern
auch hier in deutschland und zwar so
sehr dass ich mir vorgenommen habe eine
video reihe zu produzieren in der sich
besonders um eine wohnung dreht man
munkelt auch dass es mich so sehr
interessiert dass in den nächsten
monaten eine video reihe kommt in
welcher eine wohnung kaufen umbau raus
[Musik]